stavo tornando dimentichiamo oggi
guarderemo i best moment social facebook
questo punto io farei vedere quella
challenge che tipo è diventato il
campione di calcio il messico
[Musica]
allora ragazzi ma voglio bene associate
lungo e forse l'unica cia limiti in cui
lo posso vincere il natale in funzione
così abbiamo un tentativo per far
passare la palla dentro questo ciambella
questa ciambella e far cadere più
scatoloni possibile tutto fiero ma io
posso metterla
eppure è toccata la scatola stava
accadendo per pietà la scala di soldi
per una lezione è mai vista ha detto la
faccio io ecco perché si poteva anche
sfondare direttamente sembrava un po
pablo escobar tocco
però niente è meglio di poco il tester
cosa meglio di quello di partner di
bilancio come l'anno passato ma capita
una palla ma va bene così imparare
stavo banana matura anche prima della o
comunque nessun la tua madre questo
tutto il cervello ma legati anziane
queste queste serie funzionato ballini e
il balletto malissimo ha detto certo è
il livido calcolare solo 6 ma mia
whiting eppure c'è un po in su da rally
fatevi passare in mezzo non è capitato
ricordo che stavo cercando imparare io
ci provavo un altro modo se non sbaglio
con le mani no così
io faccio le veci spaccate sta perdendo
invece sta poi questa comunque la
manciata di lorenzo vi ricordo e in
un'altra challenge che ho deciso io se
lo stracciato tra l'altro quale era
sicuro col cibo
[Musica]
praga comportava per voi una sorpresina
torino un po particolare sono ciambelle
e un regalo che era pure un regalo
trovato commentatore rai italiana è un
po come ti mangio schifo ma pasta di
sesamo cimicione ogni giorno voglio un
capitale in cinque guarda alle cose
video evitare così la salsa di pesce è
un pesce tritato definirla non basta e
inflessibile come rispondere non ne so
niente né al titolo capperi e stata di
pesce a come tutta la roma nato quando
questo è buono davvero all'area queste
buone queste ragazze ce l'hai con anche
adesso magari facciamo
era fuori né una viola come la
fiorentina abbiamo un colore quella che
produce sempre mia madre era buonissimo
semmai come cosa faceva schifo che le
ciambelle più sta roba
ma in casa e fuori carciofi denis di
parigi la voglia di scambiare come
[Musica]
questa di sale prima vi do un consiglio
se nella vostra mente pensate che questa
minaccia me l'ha mai un toast clicca
questo di cannes gelato e non ci vedo
nulla di sbagliato infine le motivazioni
che insegni queste cose lei radioattiva
ragazza icona tino e basta rimaste
rimasti piccola parte proprio perche
guarda sono perso loro e di ricordo
anche ci stanno non stai challenge con
le carte che valeva era anche
leggendaria guardiamo come signori
ragazzi chi si colpisce prima vince con
la vernice fare quattro sfide che
arrivati fa più punti vincerà la sfida
mi ricordo che in questi celle non so
perché io non stavo giocando ma alla
fine sono quelle uscite
ci siamo colpiti ma ci siamo spacciati
le braccia per il collo viviamo e
abbiamo elevato del modavi perché si sa
cos'è sta roba
ma poi perché i baffi i baffi di
anonymous sembrano ci siamo visti la
gente che muore
capitolo scabeccio le sue colorate ma
non rifacciamo oggi queste bestie
jablonski vero e non so perché ero sport
cui io l'ho già in radio è dato vita
alla fine vedi che dalla crisi la
maglietta non capite niente esatto sarà
presa c'era pulito ad via l'elmo niente
qualcosa commentiamo il cras parte stai
state in faccia esatto
[Musica]
penso che può accompagnare sono era
l'ultimo punto chi vinceva quest'anno ha
vinto tutto
[Musica]
cosi alzato di servizio ipad papa in
quel caso le lotte fragoline adesso ora
sai con chi ti batti che ti ricordo che
tutto ciò che porta l'arte ci ho perso
io perché perché c'è stata nel ridicolo
è capitato così ha commentato renzo
l'uomo di latta l'uomo e picchiato prima
del qatar di avervi comunque ragazzi e
non vorrei dire però sapete tutti che
trattano benissimo e dal vivo anche non
c'è stata storia la guardiamo
[Musica]
non deve di una clava dovete usarla per
colpire il pallone fare gol
vince chi fa tre gol abbiamo fatto
negano anno che emettiamo gettare
partiamo non ce la vediamo salva e
l'osteria legge locali ma poi a due
all'ora andavamo ma che poi le rosato ha
fatto qualcosa si scontra che guarda che
poi si sono sempre
[Musica]
vuoi essere così stormo attenzione
attenzione verso il mare italiano non
capiamo
allora in guerra tanto pali in due tiri
la fascia da qualche africa del pallone
partita stava scritto dal bar
la cosa che vorrei mai che con la mano
stavi anche spagna si erano 6 a 1 e
vinci falsi lasciare il porto
raga perché c'è del saluto e mi
accompagnava sociale trovarci per
trovarvi smontare salma che si schianta
passare circa l'accaduto la cui faccia
sei da solo un libro ma dai che si
concluda da buttare una serie di mi
piace mai vi invitiamo a seguire
all
[Musica]